hi everyone and welcome to our first
gameplay live stream of marvel's
midnight suns my name is caroline gavada
producer and your host for today i am
joined by two very special guests jake
solomon our creative director
very happy to be here very happy to
finally play the game
of course and of course garthy angela's
our franchise producer thank you so much
happy to be here as well awesome well
thank you guys so much for joining us if
you haven't follow us on social media
yet please do so on twitter and
instagram again that is marvel's
midnight suns give us a follow so you
can be up to date for the latest and
greatest and also if you want a very
exclusive skin for blade or nightstalker
skin definitely sign up for our
newsletter
we're getting into some pretty
incredible stuff with caroline
all right which we are
ecstatic to show the world
probably just be able to play it again
and you know it's it's been a while and
you know on behalf of the team before we
do dive
watching the trailer watching the
gameplay assets that came out it's been
incredibly incredibly invigorating for
the team to see the reaction
from the community it really does
energize us we are going to be finishing
the game
and seeing your guys love and uh
excitement for what's to come um the
team really appreciates so thank you all
we've also been listening to your
feedback already very important to us
and one one piece we definitely wanted
to touch on was the fact that this game
is a premium title an enormous
single-player game that is brimming with
content and we're not going to have
gameplay microtransfers
no no i understand why people would
think that but no every every ability
that your heroes can have they're in the
game you only earn them by playing with
the heroes you love there are no
gameplay microtransactions so
put that to rest put that the rest let's
just let's just play the game
let's get let's go let's play guys let's
go let's do it jake
you and i used to play another game
we're not we're not quite in kansas
anymore are we no that's a little bit
different so um
you're in control of the hunter moving
her in real time there um you're at the
abbey which is an entirely new uh
superhero headquarters that we created
with marvel um every cool superhero team
has to have a cool superhero
this is ours we're just on the exterior
we're going to show more of the abbey
and at the end of this mission today
we're really showing off combat um so
we've got a couple of our squad mates
here we're gonna head into comet this is
our hunter we've talked about how
customizable they are they can look
very different from this
um we're walking by one of the other
characters on the team magic
personal favorite character in the
midnight suns
it also was incredibly important to us
and the team to have a base that
reflected something like we all knew and
loved when we were kids with marvel
avengers tower x-men and the x-mansion
now having your own base is um such a
staple that i think you need to do in a
marvel game and something that hasn't
been done before you're going to have
your own yes and and ours
that's a big part of the game is how it
comes alive how you live with these
hairs and we'll talk about that in a
little bit um and so now what we've done
is crossed over into this sort of
inter-dimensional space we call limbo so
magic opens portals you walk through
limbo and you get to your next mission
and that that's kind of one of her
powers and she can display this stuff in
combat as well
awesome so we're going to just dive
right into combat then yes all right
we're going to play some combat we are
going to play some combat and again you
know we are we are a tactics team
through and through
um i'm so proud of the designers we have
here and the folks that work with jake
and the creative systems designers but
we're we've made something that you have
not quite seen before when it comes to a
tactics game
there's so much when it comes to the
visual element of this characters and
how they're going to move and the
superhero flair that you're going to see
but first we wanted to slow down before
we start playing this thing fast let's
talk
talk
talk
about
abilities right because
as you may have heard
um the hero's abilities they're they're
dealt to you at the start of comment and
like a hand of cards
which are cards yeah timeless game
mechanic
what could be controversial about cars
nothing i assume however
in case it is i would understand why
people say uh what that's very different
from anything we've done before it
doesn't actually
i want to make sure that people
understand it doesn't play that
different than things we've done before
but as garth is playing i'm going to
explain how this this whole system works
and the idea is that
every character has their own abilities
that the player um is in charge so they
can assign whatever abilities they want
to to blade to doctor strange to the
hunter they bring all those abilities
into combat and there aren't that many
of them so you're going to see all those
abilities come up um but they're dealt
to you as a hand of cards and there's a
really cool card categories too right
yes
so uh there's three different types of
abilities that are really important
there's an attack which garth did there
um one of the benefits of abilities uh
treating them as a card is we can put
like really interesting effects on them
so we have tons of them it's another
benefit we can make so many different
abilities um we can give them
interesting effects um
one is an attack which garth showed off
there with blade the next is a skill uh
which he just used with dr strange yep
and that is the sort of thing that is a
little more could buff your um uh your
allies could be defensive there are
different ways to use it but ultimately
the important thing is that by playing
attacks by playing skills you're
building up a resource that we call
heroes you can see this in the bottom
right that's
what's that yeah it's a simple the game
all rotates around heroism right and so
you build up heroism and you use that to
then use the other third type of builder
which is called underwear they're your
most powerful attacks they can have
devastating sure
impacts on the enemies and that's what
we're working towards right here now i
have a few other plays before i use dr
strange's heroic i'm going to use one of
the hunter's attacks to build up more
heroism which will make the heroic
stronger
so right now the hunter is in a great
position to fire off this ability
yeah knock an enemy into another enemy
but you can also discretely move your
characters around the battlefield and
you don't have to um to be able to use
different abilities or um different
effects in the environment so now we're
going to trick them yeah oh no no you're
fine i always i was going to say like it
seems like you have a lot of flexibility
and freedom how you choose to play like
with your heroes yeah you do i mean the
the idea is that the game is meant to
move pretty fast it's still very deep um
i love that ability that's right
um he just hailed that person by the way
he buried an axe in their head and then
they just would not be gentle
but also i mean you saw that heroic
ability our art team and our content
team and and all the disciplines i've
worked on they have created these
abilities that are in your face
incredibly satisfying to watch over and
over and pay off yeah they've really
pushed the like the presentation of the
abilities um and it's yeah it's amazing
to see there are a lot of deep elements
to combat here and part of that is is
how different the heroes play so we have
a number of different abilities here and
in fact actually garth you can talk
about what you're about to do here yeah
we're going to use a special skill from
the hunter which is going to chain on
and allow us to use a very very powerful
card in our deck so inspire allows you
to play a heroic or a card that costs
heroism for free so that's we're going
to do hunter
and that's going to lead to this
powerful ability yeah and so the hero
combo again a big attack the way that
you unlock these abilities is actually
through the abbott so we talk about how
the relationships that you have with
these heroes and this
is very awesome and very powerful you
unlock these super powerful attacks by
forming a relationship with the heroes
involved
last man standing
oh here we go
gotta go blade i mean so again that's an
encounter you know they play very very
fast why is it that for every one of
these sites we take out it seems like
two more appear in their place patience
hydra certainly lives up to their name
i've hunted an actual hydra that was
easier easier than this
[Music]
i live up to my name too
[Music]
hell of a prized crossbones put on your
head runt
too bad he never said it had to stay
attached to your body
well
too bad for you big words
for a dead man
you got one thing right today sabretooth
heads are definitely about to roll
oh look another mangy stray
you smell
wrong
compared to him
good point
now i get to kill two rugs with one claw
maybe i should be paying hydra
okay guys i would be lying if i would
say i'm not excited about this very
iconic
duo this battle between saber tooth and
wolverine
yeah and as you saw there just one of
the cinematics we have hours of
cinematics in the game obviously we're
telling a very deep uh story and and
part of that story uh of course is
introducing these villains this is the
first villain we've shown but we have a
large cast of characters not just
heroes we've got you know again as i
said 12 marvel heroes plus the hunter we
also have a large cast of villains for
the player to fight against
it's what makes lilith um so powerful so
again she's the ultimate enemy the thing
that's cool about her if you imagine
the most dangerous people in the marvel
universe she's equally uh she's equally
dangerous because she can corrupt people
with a single touch so not only do you
fight villains like saber-tooth hair but
you'll fight what we call fallen where
lilith has corrupted villains she's
corrupted even heroes that the player is
going to have to fight against over the
course of the game so yeah very deep
narrative a lot of narrative comes out
not just through cinematics but also
you'll experience in-game as well
and now we're fighting against
sabretooth and yes you're right this is
an iconic
matchup right wolvie the best at what he
does saber-tooth
kind of good
you know he's deadly like sabretooth is
a very deadly character and so you're
gonna have to require your entire team
to take him out all of our villains have
a bunch of unique abilities and also a
unique flair to them saber tooth um the
idea the time behind sabretooth is that
he has a ability called frenzy and that
means that every time you take an action
he may respond right so you have to be
really careful you have to be very
efficient in what you do because
sabertooth responds very quickly so you
can take two actions then he's um fight
back so you have to like anticipate when
he goes on that frenzy kind of yes like
for now
but yeah i mean
i love i love
saber tooth um we've introduced you know
here we're interesting wolverine for the
first time this is where you meet him
this is
pretty far into the game probably i mean
actually this game's very long so not
that far but this is a good ten small
hours into the game um when you meet
wolverine and you unlock um him so there
are characters you unlock through play
this is the moment when you sort of meet
wolverine for the first time
and so again wolverine a completely
different play style completely unique
set of abilities
can you go into his abilities a little
bit more like what makes him so unique
and different from the other characters
yeah so if you think about wolverine
it's he's very savage um he has the
ability to attack multiple targets so he
has what we call chain
he has a lot of ability to chain to
multiple targets um and at the same time
he can taunt enemies and that means that
he can draw their fire when he attacks
them then enemies uh target wolverine
after that and that's great because
wolverine has the ability to regenerate
health uh he's very low on health here
you're doing okay buddy
i'm gonna get some lifesteal on there if
you want to mention that
i believe in you garth you can do this
as you can see uh saber tube huge huge
health bar heavy header definitely
definitely a heavy hitter and so
that's good um wolverine has got some
lifesteal going on and since i got to
the moon
but yeah this is the problem with
sabertooth right is that it just doesn't
stop and this matches how he is in the
comics as well like 72 doesn't stop you
know yep yep so you have to always kind
of be on your toes here
all right what are we doing garth like
we got him we got him okay all right
okay okay i'm actually going to
i'm going to position yourself use the
environment
right
one thing that's worth pointing out is
that as you move you can continue to
move until you use the ability right and
so you can position yourself just
perfectly until you use an ability you
can continue to move my own command and
you know the movement balance is one of
my favorite parts as as movement you
play tactics you know how critical it is
but it's this wonderful balance of you
can choose to play more methodically and
find that single precise movement
position to take advantage of the
enemies but it's not every single turn
every single action
have
to keep
going
[Music]
you'll do
[Applause]
all right so we saw a lot of good
gameplay a lot of good abilities just
like amazing amazing game play of course
but this isn't just it right garth
there's still a whole nother section to
it
there's a whole lot
it is enormous it is incredibly
incredibly exciting um again
we love tactics games and changing what
we did with the tactics design there
wasn't enough we wanted the whole other
half of the game that was the rpg part
of the tactics rpg so we're going back
to the abbey now and we're going to show
you guys a little bit of a gameplay
tease with what you can do within the
abbey and we're going to start in the
hunter's course all right let's do it
you can do
an enormous amount obviously after a
hard day's work you want to go back to
your place of refuge right you're
wearing casual clothes
many outfits we actually have a lot of
outfits but uh and look at this room it
looks like some decorating could be done
can you do decorating
yeah you gotta you gotta update the room
and yeah there's ways to update not just
the character the room as well here's
your beloved horse charlie right your
beloved hellhound charlie who loves you
so much
um
you can of course pet the dog and
there's a lot of benefits to that as
well
are we gonna be able to explore that a
little bit more we are and in fact
what's happening right now is the the
hunter walking into the common room
after combat and so again this is really
a social um experience where after
combat all these years are hanging out
and you can choose from different heroes
after combat um to hang out with and
this is an important part of building a
relationship it is it's it's one of my
favorite parts of the game not only do
you have fun in combat you come back and
you have a very very important choice to
make which is a whole other part of the
marvel fantasy right it's not just
battling amongst these heroes it's who
do you want to hang out with nico morono
or iron man right yeah and there's a lot
of benefit to this right there's not
just a narrative benefit as they
commiserate over their terrible parents
um oh my dad's not watching um because
i'm commiserating with them as well um
but yeah then then
in addition to hanging out with heroes
you obviously get to have a deeper
experience talking to different
characters around the abbey and we're
kind of alluding here like your dialogue
choices can can affect 100 balance as
well i mean it's it's an rpg there's
branching dialogue choices here you
mentioned the light dark balance the
role-playing force how you want to craft
your hunter and their personality is
incredibly compelling um and you'll be
able to do that in spades in the abbey
uh oh what are we doing here caroline
you love the dog i do your dog i i mean
it looks like it talking
leaving me somewhere special okay where
are we going so
you know this is just one of the many
things that happens on the abbey grounds
so the heavy grounds are very extensive
which you can explore and you should
and this is a lot of really interesting
optional concept that the player can
come out here explore the grounds
uncover a lot more narrative a lot more
game play um and so again
we wanted this to feel like a living
space and so it's not just the interior
of the abbey it's the exterior grounds
as well that feel you know appropriately
supernatural um
again you think of the world of marvel
it's not enough to just have
a series of menus in between missions or
a base that doesn't have a lot of
content and substitute and the grounds
really act as that since they're
overloaded with secrets and mysteries
and deep deep lore to learn more even in
other corners of marvel that you may be
surprised about the background of the
hunter and caretaker and other
characters right and there's so so much
more that we would love we would love to
show you we're going can we
there's so much more to show you and and
we will um very soon all right
all right well there you have it guys we
have a little bit of gameplay a little
bit of abby a lot of combat that's
coming up as well um what's what's
coming up guys in october coming months
a lot um so we want to dive deep on some
of the characters like start to show
more about these characters and then
show more gameplay
just we just hinted at it with the uh
the combat and the episode we want to
show more of that um in the coming hours
awesome well i'm pretty sure everyone's
looking forward to it thank you so much
guys both jake and garth for joining us
today and showing our fans of course
like marvel's midnight suns
yes we are very happy to finally be put
in the game yeah so it's incredibly
exciting thank you all thanks for uh
being with us yep absolutely all right
thank you guys if you haven't done so
already make sure to follow us on social
media again that is marvel's midnight
suns on twitter and instagram make sure
to give us a follow also sign up for our
newsletter for the very exclusive night
stalker blade skin thank you so much for
joining us today and we look forward to
sharing more
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i get excited you're very
excited